so new game
pontec wants to take take
so
this time too
good old ladies with it
or Catalan let's have a look
very early runner F4 that also
rarely
waits normally I always know until the runner
is on i7 because I can somehow
take advantage of the four well
now E3 or something like that plays yes  Exactly,
maybe I now have a chance of becoming active with
five knights E4 or something so quickly, so
it's a bit stupid here that
the bishop doesn't tie up the knight
or
can override this statement, so that
's somehow the result of
five  Knight
he can but toom C1 player maybe
I can win A2 well come on let's
try to play a bit directly
with it
there's right off it's
not that unreasonable
probably
say yes well
I'm of course not exactly brilliantly
developed through the whole action so
how good  the lens is no longer
safe at all
so how do we get
out of here as quickly as possible
at least try again very directly
the only
critical move is now actually do
one if he now
moves the bishop I either have
knight E2 yes or now I have
maybe even C4
yes C4 come where is he going now
so if he goes somewhere here
right now I can make knight E2
F4
and get rid of this bishop there
and my knight has also saved himself,
that somehow wasn't quite
sure  That's how it works, now you
just have one more and here two
potential ones to clear,
yes the whole act but it was worth it,
yes I should have perhaps thought again about
how I could take the lid after the move F3
just for F3 GFA 6
A4
or  Of course it stands like a piece of
Swiss cheese, no, even if I
lose all the pawns, there will be
six,
so yes, I still have Tom A7. I thought
that could be dangerous at first,
but the idea was actually to
just hand over the B5 too. I do
n't see exactly either  how I
should hold it, but the
question is how best to do it now so
that the knight somehow
comes into play
and I would have to play G6 again at some point
so that all this
stuff is frozen here. The
question is how to play  I
might now take away
and actually take away and it takes
a while for him to collect them all so I still have that so now
I first have to bring the knight into play here
so that was clear and I'll give that
up too,
that's what matters to me too  nothing if I
get D4 at the end then I end up with
four against four but he has this
crazy construction job, okay,
so now jump F6
now he can take it then I
do the 8
yes
I don't even lose that,
I actually have C4  Even what I
could actually have done,
I haven't
seen at all, but it's not that bad,
I can take it and C3, it's
through,
yes, it's through here, I can
hit it
painlessly